welcome to exploring computing
today's video is creating web pages
responsive web design so i've mentioned
before that one of the key differences
between
working with web pages versus working
with a printed page and one of the
reasons why
you can't just take a word processor
like microsoft word and generate a web
page from it
i mean technically you can but it's not
going to get you a very good web page
is that we don't have control over the
output
device when we're working with a web
page and we're working with a printed
page when we're working with microsoft
word we can say
oh i'm going to print this out on an
eight and a half by eleven sheet of
paper or i'm gonna print this out on a
17 by 11 sheet of paper
with the web browser we don't have that
sort of control our website
says hey this might be served up on a
little cell phone this might be served
up on a big tablet
um this might be served on a huge
desktop computer it might be served on
somebody's hd television so we have no
control over the output device
and so what we need to do is we need to
create web pages that will work for all
of these different devices
and this is kind of a problem because
the attractiveness of a web design
and the utility is going to vary from
one device size to another so something
that looks great on a cell phone it's
going to look
really stupid on an hd television if you
know we just take our cell phone design
and slap it up up
on the hd television so that's not going
to work very well
and in addition there's various user
interface or ui
elements that work well on some devices
but not others
so one example of this would be tool
tips
a lot of programs use tool tips and
people started using tool tips for
websites where you move the mouse on top
of something you let it sit there for a
minute
you get some information about that
element well that doesn't work with cell
phones because
you can't hover your finger over a
particular element
and have the cell phone realize you're
doing that in order to bring up a tool
tip
similarly you know when you're working
with your cell phone you've got your
finger which is pretty big and fat
compared to the sort of pointing device
you can get if you've got
either a mouse where you've got that
nice little thin
pointer or if you're working with
something like say a
a pencil device like say an apple pencil
when you're working on your cell phone
so in one case with
the pencil or the mouse pointer you've
got really fine grained control and you
can carefully
tap small elements on the screen and get
it right whereas if you're working with
your finger
you've got a much more coarse pointing
element and it's going to be much harder
hitting those different targets so
you know depending upon the actual
device we're working with
some designs will work really well and
some designs will work pretty badly
and so the question is how how are we
going to respond to this
so one possibility and this is the
basically the way things work for many
many many years is
that the website designers would just
set a minimum standard size and target
that
so you know i've been working on the web
since
uh i guess around 97 when i came to
stanford
uh the web's actually a little bit older
than that basically i was working on my
phd i was finishing my phd in the last
year or two of my php people were like
hey there's this cool thing called the
web you should check it out and i was
like no i'm busy
finishing my uh dissertation here and i
worked a couple years in industry and
then i came to stanford and
uh when i took over cs 105 i decided we
should be teaching web
stuff and so that's when i started
working on web technology
anyway slow aside there okay so
the way things work back in the day and
for many years
after the web first was introduced was
the websites make a decision on what
they sort of thought the
minimum type of device that people would
be visiting their website on so for a
while
websites were designed for devices that
were 640 pixels
wide or less and then they were designed
they
sort of upped it and said okay we think
that people uh
actually have slightly bigger monitors
now so let's go ahead and design our
website for people with at least 800
pixel devices
and then they redid their design for 10
24 pixel devices and in fact
you know every couple years the major
websites would do another redesign and
the reason why they were doing a
redesign is because the monitors
that they assumed that people were
visiting websites with were slightly
larger and so they'd
they'd redesign their website for that
slightly larger size
and you came to visit their website and
you had a smaller monitor
well you had to put up with uh
horizontal scroll bars because the
website did not actually fit
in the amount of space that you had and
if you came to visit that website with a
much bigger monitor well
that's too bad it was still you know
stuck on a particular size so um
that was the original way people to sign
websites for
different devices basically they didn't
okay another approach that gained a lot
of traction and still is out there
is the idea that you actually have
different websites for different devices
most notably there's often a desktop
version
versus a mobile version and we can get
this because
when you make an http request to a
website
the web browser actually sends along a
bit of information
on the user agent and so what the web
server can do is it can
look at that user agent and say oh i
think that
this particular user agent should be
sent to the desktop version or this
particular user agent should be sent to
the
mobile version of the website this also
doesn't work great
one you have to keep an updated list of
what all the different user agents are
and
where they should be sent and two
it means you're maintaining different
multiple websites one for the desktop
and one for mobile
and there are other some also some other
issues for example
i spent a lot of time on my ipad and it
turns out that the ipad often gets
shuttled off to the mobile website
which can be pretty problematic if the
mobile website's designed for a little
cell phone and you've got this nice big
screen and you're like what the heck
guys
can i take advantage of my uh 11 or 13
inch screen and they're like no
you're in the mobile website you're kind
of stuck with this okay so these are all
unsatisfactory solutions they've all
been done they've been done
professionally
there's a lot of mobile websites out
there and you know
and i on the one hand that kind of might
make sense in some cases but on the
other hand
you know i think we're blurring the
lines between what's a mobile device
how large is a cell phone what's a small
size tablet what's a large size tab on
what's a desktop computer
so there's actually a better approach
and the better approach is something
called responsive web design and so what
responsive web design is going to do is
it's going to
get information about the actual device
that the user is using it's going to ask
what the characteristics of that device
are and it's going to have
different style rules on the basis of
that device so
you know this works hand in hand with
the cascading style sheets
in order to use different cascading
style sheet rules for
different devices and as i've alluded to
before
this works great with the grid-based
layout that i'm recommending you guys
learn
all right so let's take a look at how
this might might work
um i'm gonna start off by kind of giving
an overview example and this is actually
the homework assignment for one of my
other classes
in fact this part right here you all
should recognize because this is part of
your homework assignment
um so you know you've all done this this
particular assignment here
but what i do for my cs193c class this
is a
web development class for majors that i
teach during the summer
i make them change the web design on the
basis of
what sort of characteristics of the
device that are visiting the web page
are so
in addition to what you guys have to do
when the web page gets narrower and
narrower at some point
it doesn't really make sense to have
that counter off to the right side
you can do it but what's going to happen
is that the
news article is going to get smaller and
smaller so um
so instead what we do is we move the
calendar
below the news article and then if it
gets even narrower
we no longer float the image on one side
instead we have the image take a
100 percent of the width of the web
browser window and then we put the text
of the article below it
and then we put the calendar below it so
this
is a three-stage design you can have as
many stages as you want
i'm not going to show you the source for
this because it is a homework assignment
for cs193c
and i don't want the solutions floating
around
uh okay so here's the example here's
one of several examples we're going to
take a closer look at
okay so in this case i've got a article
about the
stanford residence halls and on the left
i've got a
list of all the stanford residence halls
and so we're going to do here is we're
going to start by something pretty
simple what we're going to do is
as the web browser window gets narrower
we're just going to go ahead and
completely get rid of
that list of residence halls
um okay so how are we going to do that
it's actually pretty easy
and basically i'm just going to
introduce this concept of a media query
and we're going to talk a little bit
about what your options are
you're not actually going to have to do
this on any homework assignments but i
did want to kind of give you an idea of
how this works
and this is definitely something that if
any of you go out and create an actual
website this is definitely something you
should be thinking about
okay so um the list of the dorms on the
left that's inside of a nav
element that's one of the new html5
special semantic element
along with the article and i've
mentioned the figure and the fig caption
before so there's a nav
element and so that list of dormitories
is in the nav element we're going to see
another example a little bit later on
that we can actually take a look at the
html
but for now just just realize that that
list of
dormitories is within that element okay
normally that nav element is floated to
the left and so that's what we're seeing
in our left screenshot there but
what i do is i have this media query and
i say hey if the maximum width
of the screen is 480 pixels
in other words if the screen is 480
pixels or less
then just get rid of that nav element
just don't display it at all
and so that's what we've got on the
right okay so that definitely works
but you know for most purposes you don't
want to just get
rid of the navigational element you want
to move them and so that's what our next
example is going to do
instead of completely getting rid of the
navigational elements i'm actually going
to put them across the top of the screen
when
the window gets really narrow and so
here's how i'm doing that again i'm
floating the nav to the left
i've got a media query for a particular
width and so here you can see that
you can actually have multiple style
rules within
the media query section so if the
maximum width is 600 pixels or less
then i've got two different rules that
are going to apply first of all i'm
going to get rid of the float on the nav
element
and then i'm going to turn all the list
items
from their standard which is display
block to display inline
and so here on the right you can see
this is the actual html so you can see
i've got that nav
element i've got a unordered list i've
got a bunch of list items
and so list items are normally block
level elements
they create blocks of text similar to
divs
and so what i'm doing is i'm actually
able to change
them their behavior and say i don't want
to treat them as blog level elements
i want to treat them as remember what we
refer to as inline or
text level elements and those are are
for things for
for example we would use for the bold
tag or the italics tag
those were inline or text level elements
i'm saying i'm saying
hey i know the the list item is normally
a block but don't treat it as a block
anymore just
treat it as a as just a basically span
tag
and so you can see uh the effect is that
the list no longer goes top to bottom
instead of the list goes
left to right
okay so here i'm doing this by actually
putting the media query directly into
the style sheet
there's actually possible to do
something similar
where you just you use the media query
same as before but you've actually got
different cascading style sheet files
and so i just wanted to mention this is
impossible and you can see the syntax
here
and there's several different ways of
doing this you can use the at import
within the style tag itself or you can
create multiple link
tags to different cascading style sheet
files
okay so the last thing i wanted to
mention is just to give you a sense of
what sort of things we can ask about so
here are some of the sorts of things you
might query
uh about in order to determine which set
of style sheets
or which style rules to use um and there
are other
ones in addition to these but i think
these are probably the most important so
you can determine what the width and the
height
of a of the user's devices
um or what their window looks like you
can determine whether
their device is in landscape mode or
portrait mode so
um that basically if you're not familiar
with the terms that means whether the
person's cell phone is rotated
width-wise or or lengthwise uh you can
determine what the aspect ratio is you
can determine information about how many
colors they're able to
display you can get information about
what the screen resolution is how many
dots per inch there
are and so these are all going to
determine
what sort of look your web page should
have
and what your web page design should
look like there are also
a couple more that i think are really
interesting um
maybe that says something about what i
find interesting and says something
about me but uh
uh yeah i mentioned earlier the idea
that
depending on whether you're using your
finger to select items on a web page or
you've got a finer grain
pointer like a mouse or a
touch sensitive pen or pencil
you might have different web designs and
so you can actually find that
information you can ask
you can use a media query to say hey if
if i have a fine grain pointer i want to
use the following elements my web page
or i want my elements to be such and
such a size
but if somebody's navigating my web page
with their finger i realize they're not
going to be able to tap
these things quite as you know
fine-grained and so maybe i'm going to
increase the size of my navigational
elements
and then the hover that's the part where
you know i still really like tool tips
but
i certainly acknowledge it does not work
at all with cell phone with somebody
trying to navigate with a finger so
you can ask we say does the user have
the ability to hover
and if they're using a mouse then the
answer is yes but if they're using
their finger on the cell phone the
answer is no and so you can change your
design on that basis
anyway so this whole idea of responding
to
information about the user's device and
using your cascading style sheets to
change how the web page appears is you
know it's really
very important if you're planning to do
professional design
if you're doing let's say you end up
you're doing a non-profit or something
and
you need to create a web page because
nobody else in the nonprofit knows how
to create a web page
you can still do some basic web querying
you know if you go back to that first
example i started off with that's the
homework assignment in cs193c that's
actually fairly straightforward saying
hey i've got a couple breaks where you
know
maybe if the person's monitors 1200
pixels or more let's do this if the
person's monitors 800 pixels or more
let's do this other thing
that's actually fairly easy so you know
if you are planning to create a website
it's definitely something to consider
all right i'll talk to you all soon
you